[Musique]
what he may
what else
pour le site du groupe
comment
vraiment
m
[Musique]
la bagnole vous êtes le boss des bosses
pas faux la désinvolture attitude les
cuisses en acier la plus jolie des
fiancés
je suis en retard j'étais en train de
rassembler tous britten de la terre pour
le propulser dans l'espace où il pourra
continuer ne rien faire le mois l'appel
de ma vie c'est quoi ce délire
je m'appelle câble je viens sur ce gosse
quoi quel gosse du pouce aux tu crèves
les enfants nous rendent un peu meilleur
que ce qu'on est
il a besoin de toi ou alors toi tu es
plus futé que jordi nerfs je ne
laisserai pas câble tuer ce gamin et j'y
arriverai pas seul mais qu'un former un
groupe de la mort qui tue et voilà notre
groupe fera progressiste
paritaire est connue sous le nom de
[Musique]
ex-forces ça sent le réchauffé c'est moi
excellente remarque est maintenant
musique
m
hot mois d'août ils ont bien chauffé le
ralenti la justice c'est pas toujours
propre et si tu veux te battre pour le
bien parfois salir les doigts
le sign on pour hommes est à cette
génération ce que la coupe mulet était
aux années 80 c'est là que je m'en veux
d'avoir arrêté les études on va
satisfaire les attentes mais genre grave
plus de raison de faire un trois en or
est temps d'essayer bon s'arrête aux
deux essais du riz
[Musique]